ce sont des guépards des chars allemands
spécialisés dans la défense en tirer une
cinquantaine vont être livré à l'ukraine
ce qui est important maintenant c'est
que le soutien à l'ukraine viennent
rapidement à ce que le matériel que nous
livrons soit est efficace et surtout
tout soit fait en coordination avec nos
partenaires et alliés nous n'avons pas
de temps à perdre la réunion
d'aujourd'hui montrent combien les
semaines à venir vont être cruciales
pour l'ukraine face à cette aide
matérielle toujours plus massive la
russie s'inquiète et ressort la menace
de l'armé nucléaire le spectre de la
troisième guerre mondiale
les risques sont vraiment considérable
l'association et je ne voudrais pas
élevé artificiellement ces risques tous
les discours encore une fois sur
l'utilisation possible d'armes
nucléaires est dangereuse et
irresponsable
personne ne souhaite un conflit
nucléaire et personne n'a à gagner on
voit comment ces choses aussi peuvent
dériver comment un certain nombre de
voix s'accumulent dans le sens qui est
dans l'intérêt
notamment les états unis je dirais
plutôt à poutine nous sommes plus forts
que vous beaucoup beaucoup plus fort que
vous et vous ne pouvez plus jamais
utilisé le mot nucléaire si vous le
faites il va y avoir des problèmes
question bouton le vice premier ministre
de belgique a clairement joué le jeu
avec ce cliché accompagné d'un trait
d'humour c'est comme ça qu'on gagne des
élections ces jours ci vous entendez la
france info 12h10 on est ouvert on tend
la main mais derrière nous derrière jean
luc mélenchon ça peut pas ça marchera
pas mais ça marchera pas la pression
vous faites là je suis
contre le mur reculé tout
pourquoi c'est une réflexion de
journalistes il faut de la clarté de la
clarté où on est mort pour gouverner
avec emmanuel macron et beaucoup de noms
qui circulent on regarde ce que m'a
donné un ministre tout à l'heure sont le
sous le manteau emmanuel macron pourrait
nommer des profils plus technique mme
alexis colère son bras droit à l'elysée
elisabeth bornes la ministre du travail
grande favorite des sondages en macro ni
c'est des questions qui méritent à peut
pas besoin de tant que simplement comme
ça vous voyez ça fait 5 donc je m'oppose
à emmanuel macron hewitt 5 ans je lui
dis embrassons nous folleville parce que
je pourrai pas les ch'tis
est ce qu emmanuel macron est pas une
coalition avec nous si c'est pour
disparaître
on a besoin de personne on peut le faire
tout seul la maire de canteleu mélanie
boulanger a été mise en examen si son
adjoint pour complicité de trafic de
stupéfiants les ont été placés sous
contrôle judiciaire mais l'année
boulanger son agent avait été placé en
garde à vue le 8 octobre dernier lors
d'un coup de filet anti stupéfiants en
pleine circulation un fourgon blanc
prend la fuite emprunter le trottoir à
contresens
on entend des coups de feu des hommes à
pied et en véhicule le poursuivre
c'est une opération anti-drogue qui
vient de se dérouler les enfants sont
super les enfants sont formidables
chaque jour il publie une nouvelle vidéo
sur tik tok en échange le réseau social
lui versent jusqu'à 25000 euros par mois
en fonction de son succès sur cette
photo on distingue le chargement au
milieu de ces sacs de la cocaïne
c'est cette cargaison que de trafic ont
tenté de récupérer lorsque la police est
intervenue
tik tok fabrique des ados ultra-riches
la plus fortunée sur la plateforme la
voici charlie d'amelio u17 grâce aux
revenus versés par tik tok et les
marques dont elle assure la promotion
elle a gagné l'an dernier tenez vous
bien 17 millions de dollars il souhaite
défendre la liberté d'expression
elon musk l'homme le plus riche au monde
rachète twitter pour 44 milliards de
dollars elon musk contre réduire les
contrôles au strict minimum légal donc
toujours interdire le racisme les appels
à la violence mais permettre aux
opinions les plus controversées de
s'exprimer y compris les fêtes news le
complotisme etc